Brooklyn nine-nine you have an amazing
cast the show was terrific you guys won
the Golden Globe last year you did got a
SAG nomination very excited oh yeah
I'm just gonna imagine that's a fun show
I enjoy watching the show it must be a
fun show to work on it seems like you're
a fun physical group of people there
it's a very fun group everyone loves
what they do everyone gets along we have
a terrific staff of writers and you know
they write a lot of great physical
comedy for me some stunts like you know
crashing through doors this this not
which for a comic actor is kind of like
a very exciting stunt just even crashing
through a door there was once that I
almost did which was getting lit on fire
last season my character Boyle
accidentally catches his jacket on fire
and I talked to the stunt coordinator
skyed Norman Howell just won an Emmy
last year he was on board and the
producers were down to down with it and
then the the higher-ups Fox kind of
caught wind of this idea and like now
let's let's not let her act on fire not
a good idea I mean - they're you know
it's bad business I mean they were right
I think that's very flattering for you
because I've been lit on fire many times
and no one says anything camera guy over
here is like light him up
Bruce is like torching he's a monster
laugh away pal
you